hello believe nation
welcome to the evan carmichael show i am
your host evan carmichael and today
we're talking about how to grow your
business if you're struggling if you're
not getting the momentum you're looking
for if you're not where you want to be
yet this show is for you
and you know there's a lot of lies with
entrepreneurship out there nobody talks
about how hard it is right how how
struggle how much of a struggle this is
to get your business and your idea off
the ground you know
you see the pictures and the stories and
the people who are making millions and
you think it's going to be great and you
launch your company and you know you're
your own boss you have to deal with
people you don't like you can set your
own hours
but nobody talks about how hard it is
and and a lot of entrepreneurs man we
suffer in silence you don't know who to
talk to you feel ashamed
and this show is about making you
successful okay today i'm talking about
how to beat the competition you know
whatever industry you're in you have a
ton of competition and how are you going
to stand out that's what we're going to
cover in the next hour and i'm really
excited to be with you all right how do
we stand up from the competition the
first thing the very first thing you
have to understand is you need to stand
for something
what do you stand for i want you to pick
one word that defines who you are and
bring that to your business how are you
going to be making the world a better
place that's what i want to know because
if you can make me feel something about
your company about your brand i'm much
more likely to want to buy from you if
you can't make me feel anything if i
can't tell the difference between you
and your competition then the only thing
i'm going to make a decision on is price
and you don't want to play that game
competing on price is a race to the
bottom
nobody wins in that game there's always
somebody who's willing to undercut you
just to get the experience they'll do it
for free just to get the experience so
you need to demonstrate why you're
different make me feel something towards
your brand so i'm going to come back and
buy from you and let me give you an
example just kind of bring this home
i had a caller call into the show not
too long ago who uh she cut grass she
was a landscaping company
and
there's tons of people who do this right
tons of people she's up against high
school kids who want to do this as a
part-time job so how does she stand out
how did she
charge enough money so that she can
actually make a decent wage off of this
and i asked her what's so important
about your business because the service
that she's offering is the same right
i'll cut your grass i'll point your
shrubs it's the same as everybody else
so how do you stand out without just
competing on price and she said you know
i started this business
because i really care about family and i
treat everybody's lawn like it was my
mother's house
now we're talking now that's a feeling
right she needs to build her entire
business around that feeling of family
because if i see that if i go to a
landscaper's website and i just see
grass cutting services and all different
things you can do for me i'm just going
to compare them price and see who has
the cheapest price and go with them but
if i come across her website and she's
telling me that she's going to treat my
house
like it's her mom's house that really
shows the level of commitment that
really shows care now i'm feeling
something towards her and i'm gonna be
willing to pay her more
for that premium service because i know
my property is being looked after
properly and is really being careful
i'll pay a premium for that
because she made me feel something
you already stand for something
you're just not expressing it you gotta
bring that to your business so i want
you to find the one word that defines
who you are so for her it was family
what defines you what one word defines
who you are and bring that to your
company
one more quick example
i did an interview recently with the
guys from honda's company and
christopher gavigan is the co-founder
with jessica alba the movie star and
their company is called the honest
company their one word is honest and
they bring that to their business so
much so that they named their business
the honest company and their website is
honest.com and everything they sell
relates to to honesty somehow so they
sell baby products they sell beauty
products but they want you to feel like
when you're buying a baby product when
you're putting this diaper on your kid
that has been made with honesty that
there's no chemicals in there that it
hasn't been processed too much that what
you're putting on your family is good
for them
everything is made with honesty
and so people are willing to pay a
premium to shop with them because they
feel the same way if you love honestly
you're going to love that business and
if you don't then you go back to them
and that's okay by the way that company
right now is started up still but they
are at 150 million dollars in revenue
that's the power of using your one word
and standing for something bringing it
to your business i want to get to the
calls i have
dillas on hold dildos where are you from
how can i help hi good ass good morning
actually i'm actually from new york city
welcome to the program what's up
thank you i actually enjoyed the salsa
that you had in the beginning that's
amazing what did we want i wanted to
dance
i i was dancing i was dancing here in
studio i love it that's my theme song
it's great
awesome i'm actually i'm a
life coach motivational speaker and i
just recently just published myself uh
my first self-published book it's called
your
no
your life your purpose or explanations i
have to get that correct and i just
wanted to know what was the best way to
go about marketing and promoting my book
because it's a self-help book and within
the book i actually use my own personal
experiences with each chapter as you
were saying about being honest and
allowing people to know that you you
definitely care and you're concerned
about people so the word for me that i
would choose would be compassionate
compassionate cool i love it what's the
biggest thing i'm going to learn from
reading your book
um you would pretty much for me i think
a lot of things would resonate for you
of um things that
are important to you in your life like
value
purpose
knowing that your self-worth and you are
of priority and
the same way you would bend over
backwards for other people the same way
that you would make sure that you know
that um
you matter and you're important you have
to put yourself first
cool so what i want you to think about
is distribution
who has an audience
that relates to your book so i mean
you're calling to the show that's a
great example already you know my
audience is entrepreneurs
a lot of entrepreneurs they care about
self-development they care about living
their life having a purpose
you know right away i talked about
finding your one word and applying to
your business so we're speaking the same
language but it's reaching out to more
audiences so i would make a list of
every
newspaper magazine blog popular twitter
person
popular youtube channels who all
stand for something similar who speak in
the same language right if it's somebody
who's on you know just starting off
about you gotta go make more money money
is the only thing that matters you know
pitching that guy is probably not gonna
be a good result for you
but people who are kind of aligned with
what you're talking about finding your
purpose compassion
and reaching out to them and saying hey
i totally agree with what you're doing
here's what i love about it i've written
this book i'd love to do some kind of
work together be a guest on your show
you know whatever they're doing be a
resource for them but you need to know
that's amazing a lot of people who have
an audience because for you going one by
one by one the people takes
way too long
yeah that's very true i appreciate that
that um i thought about that before but
the way that you worded it was actually
it gives me a better perspective of how
i should go about doing it so i thank
you for that
yeah even think about people who you
follow now are you on social media
i am i'm actually on facebook twitter uh
instagram linkedin so i'm on pretty much
all the different social media pages are
you on youtube
i am on youtube
okay so i would even look right now at
who you're following on all those
accounts like who you whose stuff that
you read
that you actually care to read right so
some people on twitter you may follow
for business reasons whatever but like
people whose tweets or youtube videos
you would miss if they don't post
anymore
because those people you're already
aligned with them unconsciously like
they don't know who you are yet but you
are already a fan you can speak to
their audience because you are their
audience and that's that's the place i
would start with those people who you're
already following already love what they
do and reach out to those people and
start that connection
great
i'm jotting all this down when i'm
talking to you right now
i love it hey what what's the website
for your book
um the website for my book is my my name
dylan davis dot com so it's d h y l l e
s d v d davis.com
awesome thank you so much for calling in
good luck with the book and uh and keep
you posted with your progress
i will thank you i'll be listening in
thanks phyllis
hey for all of you out there who are
trying to promote a new product you know
the hardest way to do it is to go one by
one by one by one they can you can feel
lost because you feel like you know i've
already
reached my point of saturate with my
friends and family you know they don't
they don't want to hear from any more
about this thing
but it's finding people who already have
an audience and think about people who
you already look up to you already
respect
and connect with them
and reach out to them and be a resource
show your love support them and offer
yourself up as a resource for an
interview for a quote or a video to do
with them whatever it is
be that resource to help them
and they'll help reach a much bigger
audience for you
all right today we're talking about how
to beat the competition how to stand out
how to how to get to where you want to
be with your business and i want to talk
about using the media okay our last
caller bill is had a book and i said you
got to get into the media you got to get
distribution and i want you guys to
think about
offline media and online media i want
you to find people who believe the same
thing as you do right i believe that as
an entrepreneur you find your one word
you start your movement you're on a path
to make the world a better place somehow
if you're just making money you're not
going to make it you have to have that
higher purpose and when you connect with
other people who believe the same thing
as you do
who have that same core belief we're
trying to make that same positive change
in the world magic happens
and what i want you to think about is
how to reach members of the media who
believe the same thing and it's
traditional media it's it's you know new
york times wall street journal forms or
whatever is related to your industry but
then also look at bloggers and look at
people who are youtube stars and look at
people who have big twitter following
and think about
you know who like who you can reach out
to who's already sending the same kind
of vibe out
and reach out to them and do an
interview and be a resource and support
the stuff that they're doing
you know if you pitched me for example
if you wrote to me and said evan i
believe in entrepreneurs right away i'm
paying attention
right away because that's what i stand
for i love it and if you have a product
or service that will help entrepreneurs
somehow then i'm probably going to have
you on my show i'm probably going to
tweet about you i might make a youtube
video about you and it's as simple as
reaching out to people who have an
audience who believe the same thing as
you do those people are looking for
people like you
to support and to showcase and to show
off because you're on the same mission
as they are to make the world a better
place so start making your list online
media offline media and start reaching
out i want to get to the calls we have
jen on the line jen where are you from
and how can i help
i'm from new york city
back-to-back new yorkers i love it
what's up
so i've been a stand-up comic i'm a blue
comic for
about five years now
and
yeah i've been
you know people tell me i'm like joan
rivers george carlin put together i have
a potty mouth we'll put it that way
especially on online media i like to
shock people
my problem is my mom
merged with my old public relations firm
so now we have a very large public
relations firm that handles politicians
celebrities um people in higher you know
places
and
i'm head of social media so it's sort of
like a conflict like i'm scared to like
put myself and be myself anymore because
i don't want to ruin the company for my
mom and my family and what will
potentially be mine in the future
so i don't know how to balance it out
without bringing the company down but
still being able to be myself and make
people laugh at the same time
can you help bring in a new wave of
people who need pr
but that fit well with your your style
so not the politicians but
you know the george carlins of the world
we've tried i mean we have one but one
is you know how many millions and
millions and millions of people are on
social media and online and you know
once you say something and social media
it's like stuck there forever
yeah people have to judge you so i'm
like at a crossroads this could be a uh
this is a really important moment you
know because a lot of people who who
have the potty mouth and see the wrong
things
are really bad at pr and don't know how
to how to solve it and don't know how to
resolve it afterwards and they need
somebody to help them you know think
about how many bad pr instances someone
like kanye west has had
right he seems to always fall off about
something and he believes it but there's
always enough in this big pr debacle
like he could use someone like you
someone who like he speaks his mind
but then he needs somebody to help him
you know get guided through that process
and
you could be you could fill that role i
think much better than you could for a
politician or someone who's super
straight laced and is worried about
every single word that they're saying
so so we should basically like open up
like another section of the company like
for the body mouth of the world and let
me handle them is that what you're
saying yeah and with you running it
you know like it's your mom's idea
if your mom is um
you know straight lace and
conservative and you know and she
attracts those people to the business
right and that's like they love her the
politicians will love her the ceos will
love her she works well with them but
they meet you and you know they might
not be the right vibe
yeah but if you met kanye or if you met
you know one of these stars howard stern
whatever it is who
has that brash abrasive style
you're gonna get along way better with
them than your mom will
oh yeah for sure
and those guys need help too i think
they need help more than the ceos and
politicians because they're getting a
lot more trouble
yeah so like a crisis management
department
well even
it may start with a crisis that you help
them get through but then also helping
them
in in you know preventing future ones
ongoing or maybe designing ones on
purpose i don't know maybe that's part
of the game is is getting out there and
being controversial and how to spread
that message
so but i mean but a lot of the times
it's not it's just some 3 a.m drunken
stupor they're in and they and then they
get themselves in trouble because once
you see something it's there forever it
lingers on and it cyber spacious loves
to let it stay there for
eternity
right so like what do i do about that
you know how do i solve that problem how
do i best address it that that's why i
want to hire you
great idea and i have to pass that along
to uh the big boss and see how she likes
it
i know it's hard working with family but
uh
it can be it can be great like you know
the loyalty is never questioned
but yeah we're going family definitely
definitely hard
yeah i think i think you especially if
your aim is to take over this business
at some point like you gotta you gotta
start making it your own and feel like
you're comfortable in your own skin
as long as you're feeling uncomfortable
and you're closing your mouth and you're
not being really who you are you're
never going to have huge success with it
so
um i think as soon as you can start
making it your own bringing on clients
you enjoy working with and there's a
huge demand there's a huge need for that
service i think your business will be a
lot more successful
well thank you so much that was great
advice definitely not what i expected
but that was that's awesome thank you
all right ken thanks for calling in
have a great day you too
and for everybody listen you gotta
follow your flow man you gotta listen to
your heart you gotta do things that
you're passionate about because
the longer you stay in a position where
you can't be yourself
and you can't feel the love of the
people around you and create something
that you're really pouring your heart
into if you're not at that place you're
never going to be able to create
something great
you're never going to really be a happy
person you want to be able to pour your
love into something and not just live
for the evenings and weekends right your
business should be an expression of who
you are
you've got to make that important
you've got to tie that in
and bring yourself
to your business today we're talking
about how to beat out your competition
and i'm really excited to have a special
guest with me on today athena barmaxis
is the vice president and gm of small
business services for american express
and every quarter they do a survey
interviewing entrepreneurs getting
really valuable data and information and
research to help small businesses grow
and this quarter their survey was on
competition so i thought hey this is a
great topic i gotta get athena on the
show to talk about it athena thank you
for joining us today
thank you for having me evan
awesome so
tell me you know why did you do this why
did you pick competition you pick a
different topic every quarter why
competition this time around
we really wanted to speak to small
business owners about competition
because
competition affects everyone businesses
large and small and we really wanted to
get under the covers and understand how
do small business owners think about
competition are they concerned about it
how do they tackle it do they do
different things to approach competition
so that was really you know the key
reason behind
learning more about competition and how
small business owners view it
so what did you find what were some of
the highlights from the report
well firstly the most important thing is
we were really happy to hear that small
business owners say competition is an
integral part of their business in fact
said they get it they know it's
important and 77 of business owners said
that competition actually keeps them on
their game so it helped them
deliver more value to their customers
and help them think about their business
in ways on how they can improve it so
this was really encouraging for us uh to
see that business owners embrace it and
make the best of it
and so what what are entrepreneurs doing
to beat their competition to stay ahead
well first of all one of the important
things to think about is that business
owners say competition constantly makes
them work hard for their customers so
three quarters of business owners said
customer service is critical in staying
ahead of their competition so the first
thing that they do is make sure that
they're delivering great service and
value to their customers it's about
developing a strong relationship and
providing outstanding customer service
as their number one
priority and 97 percent of business
owners agree that keeping clients happy
is the best way to be competition but on
top of that one of the things that
business owners told us fairly
consistently
is that
they're working on ways to improve their
business and in order to do that they
need to keep on top of industry industry
uh trend so 84 percent of business
owners said they prioritize monitoring
industry industry trends what's going on
how are other companies reacting to
things in the marketplace how are other
companies and their competitors big and
small developing new products new
services uh promotions and they also
report that business owners they keep a
close eye on their competitors
through their customers so
almost uh just over half said they use
word of mouth uh what are other
competitors doing and and hearing from
hearing about that and they also ask
their customers um what's uh finding out
information about what competitors are
doing so they're using a number of
different sources to keep on top of the
competition and also keep on top of
industry trends so they're ready to
react
that's awesome how do you how do you
find and pick the entrepreneur is it are
they startup are they
you know 10 employees 50 employees is it
a mix how do you find these people and
who's it made up of
we're really looking um across the
country and it's made up of a mix of
small business owners with
few employees right up to 100 employees
and we focus on really doing a mix
across industries across geography so we
do our best to speak to business owners
that really would represent a large
portion of a typical business owner
across the country
and now you do these every quarter right
every quarter is a new survey coming out
absolutely every quarter and we focus on
a hot topic and um
in this particular topic too with
respect to competition um we did
actually get some themes that we heard
about in previous
monitor so one of the things that's a
recurring theme is about customer
service and even when we focus on how do
business innovate how do they improve
their products and services
one of the monitors that we looked at
talked about how do business owners
build loyalty with their customers and
what's interesting it really comes back
to that one-on-one relationship that
business owners are adopting and making
sure that they're entrenching their
existing customers building those strong
relationships and looking to get greater
value out of those existing customers
and making sure you know a one-time
customer turns into a repeat customer so
it's really encouraging to see that you
know customers are the ones who are also
benefiting from competition because
business owners are taking a lot of the
information and industry trends and
looking at what other competitors are
doing and it's making them look at hey
do i have the best products and services
should i be innovating should i be
changing my business to make sure that
i'm
staying ahead of the curve and keeping
my customers happy so it's really
encouraging to see that because not only
do the customer win with greater service
and greater value but of course the
small business wins because repeat
customers means that the business can
continue to grow
you know what motivated you to to make
these quarterly reports because you know
you don't see too many big businesses
really say hey we care about the small
businesses usually they care about the
big guys so what what made you just want
to start this up and share all these
resources for entrepreneurs
yeah absolutely so american express
is very dedicated to the small business
owner and one of the things that we're
very focused on doing is of course not
only growing our business but in order
to do that we have to adopt many similar
principles to
other businesses large and small and
that includes delivering value to our
customers and making sure that we're
heading we're staying ahead of the
trends in the marketplace and adopting a
quarterly monitor allows us to listen to
small business owners across the country
at least four times a year and we really
get a sense of what's on their mind
what are they thinking about how are
they reacting to
hot topics whether we're talking about
competition whether we're talking about
customer loyalty whether we're talking
about how they're building their brands
or their views around
cash flow and
and managing cash flow patterns in their
day-to-day business and this is really
important information for us because it
allows us to make sure that we stay
close to not only small business owners
that use the american express small
business products and solutions but
other business owners across the country
to make sure that we are integrating
their thinking and what they're looking
for into the ways that we build products
and we service our customers so it is
very important for us and part of the
ongoing research that we feed back into
making sure we deliver that value
and
we stay close to the customer that way
the other thing that we do is keep a
close eye on an index part of what we do
is not only have a conversation about a
hot topic that we choose
but we also want to understand um a
confidence index so our small business
owners feeling more confident about
their financial position on a quarter to
quarter basis less confident how are
they feeling about the ways in which
they want to be investing in their
business and taking risks with either
capital expenditures or
hiring new employees so that that
confidence index also gives us a good
pulse on uh how business owners are
feeling about their own particular
businesses from a financial health
standpoint
cool so what did you find are we more
confident or less confident from last
quarter
so business owners are displaying a
healthy increase in their overall
business outlook so holding off of last
quarter yeah it's really encouraging so
building off of last quarter's increase
they continue to experience higher
optimism levels compared to this time
last year so you know over half of
business owners report their current
financial position has increased that's
up seven points since last quarter and
it's up 13 points since may of last year
so it's really encouraging to hear
business owners say that hey i expect my
business to continue to grow and i
expect their financial position to
remain healthy and the other interesting
thing that we monitor is how are
business owners feeling about the
advantages of running a small business
and you know close to 90 percent of
business owners remain convinced that
the advantages of running a small
business far exceed the risks and
challenges that's up three points
since last quarter and it's up uh four
points from a year ago so
even though business owners you know
continue to field might feel mild stress
and certainly they're reacting to some
of the macroeconomic indicators some of
the things that are going on in their
local communities
some of the things that their
competitors are reacting to they
continue to remain optimistic and they
continue to find the tactics to uh
you know entrench loyalty with their
customers grow new customers and see
their business grow
awesome athena thank you so much for
calling in for everybody watching and
listening you can check out the american
express
small business monitor for quarterly
updates athena thank you so much
thank you evan
all right cheers
welcome back to the everytime i go show
i believe in entrepreneurs and today's
show is about how to beat the
competition you've already shared a lot
of great ideas and information i want to
drop you with one more value bomb
form alliances okay what i want you to
do is find people who are already
selling stuff to your target audience
and find a way to work together because
again selling one to one to one to one
is a long difficult process
think about
the people who your customers are buying
from before they buy from you so before
they're calling you know you up or
checking out your website who else are
they buying from who are the other
suppliers that they need to connect with
other companies they need to purchase
from before they work with you and then
go talk to those companies and introduce
yourself and let them know what you
stand for and try to form some kind of
partnership to work together
a quick example when i had my first
software company
we wanted to expand overseas okay we
wanted to grow our company global and
you know we didn't have the resources
the knowledge how to connect with people
you know customers overseas and so they
said you know what i'm going to form
alliances and i found companies who
could represent my business in the
different markets because when i'm going
to japan i don't know japanese i don't
know the culture i can't answer the
phone in their time zone it's better to
work with the japanese government to
take care of it so find companies who
are already selling to your target
audience people are who are they're
buying from these guys before they buy
from you introduce yourself set up a
coffee go meet with them
find a way to work together if it's
commission percentage of a deal just
straight up you know referring each
other whatever it is get on their radar
screen and make that introduction i have
time for one last caller i have sherry
on the line sherry where are you from
and how can i help
hey evan it's your jersey girl again um
i had talked to you previously uh about
my caning business a few weeks ago nice
one to give you an update yeah i don't
know
so um interesting what's going on on the
show today i happen to have a business
partner now
so
i wanted to talk to you about
um we need to come up with a name for
the company right
um
i'm really like gung-ho about this which
i think if you remember last time i was
like
um if you could give me just a quick
idea of how to just you know
knock that out without having to make it
too complicated um because we're in
jersey and you know the the way that
legal things go over here is kind of
yeah but you know what i mean
so you try to find a name for your
company
um yeah i just want you to give me like
you know
tweet me in the right direction as far
as how me and her can go and
we're working on the kicking them around
right now for the names um i just want
to see if you could give me an easier
way of attacking uh you know filling
with the paperwork and what i need to do
to get get that name taken so that we
can start labeling products and all
got it okay so
the first thing we're going to make sure
is that you can get the domain name
so whatever your company name is can you
get the website can you get the com
yep and and maybe do you already have it
no we we have a couple kicked around
we're still we're still working on it
but we're close we're close
okay so i would make sure that you can
get that domain name check if it's
available and if it is buy it even if
you're thinking about a name just buy it
because it's costing you like 10 bucks a
year or something um oh yeah it's
helpful it's helpful to have that if you
don't want to launch a business and then
not have that domain name um i'd also
make that all the social media accounts
are are free so whatever that name is on
twitter on youtube on facebook
make sure that all those are free that
you can sign up for okay then
you know you have to go register your
business and you're going to register it
as a a partnership congratulations
thank you
um i'm writing down yeah and when and so
they could do a name search for you if
you want when you go register your
business they can do a name search and
see if anybody else is using that name
if there's any issues with it a lot of
times though that'll be um
nowadays an easy way to do that is just
to check for the domain name like it's
not 100 bullet proof but if nobody's
using the domain name then that's
probably not anybody who cares way too
much about that business name is going
to come in and sue you and say hey
change the name um
but uh yeah you set that up i would
strongly suggest having a strong
shareholders agreement i don't know if
you've worked with a lawyer or yet on it
um because as great as everything yeah
is at the start with a partner it's
awesome you know they could bring in
great ideas and hopefully work really
well together but you never know if it's
going to last all the way and it's great
to have a good cheerleaders agreement
just in case
okay
that's a good idea the two things i'd
really look for in that is one uh have a
shotgun clause
um which basically means that one person
can buy the other person out if you need
to at some point in the future
and uh
the other is a piggyback clause where
basically if um if you guys decide hey
we're gonna sell the company then both
of you sell it together not you sell it
to somebody or or your business partner
sells their share to
you know their brother who you hate and
then you're stuck with this
yeah right all these things that if you
work out with a lawyer and a good
child's agreement at the start then uh
in case any of these things happen down
the road you're
you're
protected and covered
perfect that's the you killed it you
just killed it for me this is awesome
any question i could have even asked
further you already took care of it
honey how do you roll
when are you gonna lie about
um we're we are going to be working
really hard on this uh during the fall
and definitely during the winter thing
you know because we'll be indoors and
remember i told you i love to cook and
soda she um we're on the same plane as
far as like uh
healthy eating and all that um
definitely gonna get get our hands into
it in the next few months so i hope i
can keep checking in with you and let
you know what's going on because you're
getting some
yeah hey you know what i'm on every two
weeks this could be uh
regular series the sharing update oh the
cleaning business the sherry series
we'll have to come up with a better name
for that then
there you go since you're in that naming
zone right now maybe you came up with a
good name for that as well
i know you can tell how happy i am paul
thank you so much for something i've
always wanted
all right evan you take care have a good
one you too and good luck with the
company
all right bye evan
all right and you know for all you who
are thinking about naming a company
young make sure you have the domain name
available make sure you get the social
media accounts i don't stress out too
much if you look at famous companies on
how they started you look at their names
you know virgin was started because they
were all verges in business so that's
that's what they did xerox they wanted
uh a hard name on purpose because they
felt like once you
once you remember it you'll never forget
it you know apple was taken from adam
and eve and and that was their they said
you know if we come up with a better
name then
we'll change it otherwise just run with
this for now and they stuck with them
became the most valuable company in the
world so ideally pick a name that means
something to you that has some feeling
to it has some
importance but also you know make sure
you can get all those domain names and
social media accounts covered up
we're already up at the end of the hour
thank you so much daniella josh you guys
are awesome josh have a great time at
the concert everybody listening have a
great two weeks and i will see you soon
continue to believe